hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
i've got a new episode for you um
one of these trends that started in last
two or three years maybe four years is
uh
building audio files switches network
switches
um you get two reactions to that anybody
in the computer space immediately says
yeah that's a foolish thing no way an
ethernet switch
can make a difference and then you have
the audio files at the other extreme
that say oh i put one in my system i
made a knight and a difference
and i don't know why but
it you know it made a huge difference so
they must work
so you know we could just argue with
words but it's
always better to add some data to the
discussion and that's what i set out to
do
last year and i think the year before
that with a couple of kind members
buying these products and uh sending
them to me
for both uh objective analysis and
measurements
and also for uh with listening tests
so uh let's switch to that and uh
start our discussion uh first let's
start with the
plain old uh ethernet switch gigabit
switch you can buy these eight port ones
for
next to nothing 20 bucks if i built an
empty box
and shipped it to cost more than 20
these companies do it manufacture
something and send it out this cheap i
don't know but
regardless to say these the technology
is heavily commoditized and it has been
for years and years and years what is a
network switch if you're not a
ito computer guy it basically takes one
ethernet
connection and gives you uh
a number extra one so the put
any port can communicate with any other
port and depending on the throughput you
can have concurrent
connections going on so uh at my desk
for example i have one and lets me
connect multiple
uh product multiple computers and audio
products
to one ethernet jack in the wall
a key thing to understand about these
products is that in a home application
where
the runs are very short
ethernet switches are guaranteed to be
reliable
there's uh you know no chance for the
signal to degrade so much that
uh you drop packets and what have you
and i've got to switch
48-port switch that powers the entire
house here
and uh once every few months i look at
the statistics and
absolutely has zero zero data drops
now you could lose packets for other
reasons for use wi-fi you can use a lot
of packets
but when it comes to home wiring and the
short wires that we use
this is just as guaranteed as you can
get as far as reliability
now from networking point of view we
actually have uh
checks and balances on that in that the
standard
protocol or communication language we
use on top of
ethernet is called tcpip and
tcp uh it's called transmission control
protocol and its job is to
provide a point-to-point communication
but
also guarantee reliability and what that
means is that it'll send packets
or chunks of data to their receiving
system and once in a while the receiving
system will send what is called an
acknowledgement
back saying hey i got that range of data
you're good
and until he hears that it actually
holds on to the data and if it never
hears that
uh message back it will actually
retransmit the packet
and the receiver then you know if the
data has been lost
it uh gets that back there is another
protocol called udp
that doesn't do that but it's not a
common protocol so
when you're browsing the web the reason
is so reliable despite so many computers
and so many flaws that could happen
so many bad things that could happen to
your packets across the internet
everything seems reliable right you're
seeing me right now and
you know the texting or youtube windows
all accurate and what have you it's
because of the power of tcp
um was invented decades and decades ago
and is the foundation foundation of
internet
because of that if you
take two compute a server in your home
and a client
streaming player network streamer and
you play content
you're guaranteed to get a reliable
transmission either because
ethernet itself is so robust in a home
environment but also because
tcpip on top of that will retransmit if
needed
now if you use wi-fi again that's a
different story wi-fi is rf
and interference can cause issues there
and tcp again tries to provide reliable
communication but if the data gets lost
for long enough time
you'll get your playback will stop and
and restart
and but in no case
even in that scenario there's a fidelity
reduce you may get buffering where
things start and stop but because tcp is
always robust and always retransmits
the final data that you get is very
reliable
so actually nobody thought we needed
anything better than that
for audio you know when we're playing
something from a
nas server for example or another
computer that has your files on it
or from a streaming service on the web
um once the bits they're all bits
they're digital data that's coming we're
not dealing with analog transmission
so the common thinking is that
once that's all the switch needs to do
it needs to get the data
and get it to you and reliably
through tcp protocol so why do we need a
audio file switch you know what are
these things supposed to do
the standard pitch for these products is
that
they want you to think that they reduce
noise and jitter
these things make a lot of sense to a
typical audiophile they may not know
what jitter is
they may not not even know how noise
gets generated but their
intuitive concepts that noise must be
bad
and that jitter must be bad
and any device that reduces those two
factors
must be a good thing now ethernet just
like any other protocol
physical connection physical transport
it's subject to noise and is subject to
jitter
but once it captures the data the
receiver
from then on the data is digital the
concept of the jitter
upstream is gone there is no such
concept anymore
because you have digital bits you can
store them in a file the file has
no notion of a noise or jitter
it has basically thrown out whatever
problem there was upstream
if that you had too much jitter and you
had too much noise
then the data would have gotten lost and
you would have gotten a glitch and a
drop out again that happens with
wi-fi but not with ethernet so
uh but then you know then are we
done do we just you know declare this
you know open and shut case
well not quite the moment you
connect the ethernet wire from a switch
to receiving let's say a streaming
device audio device
you don't have a physical connect
connection between the two
and in the theoretical world
if that source is noisy because you
don't have this electrical connection
that noise can travel in theory to the
receiver
and it can bleed into the sensitive
parts of a streamer or a dac
and pollute this output now
ethernet is designed to be robust
against noise so it has
transformer and isolation anyway but
let's say that
that stuff doesn't exist uh that the
cable just comes into the receiver and
could inject noise and jitter and that
can't happen
in theory we there are ways for example
if i take a dac that's not well designed
hook it up to usb
the noise and from usb can actually
travel to the output of the dac even
though bits are bits digital data is
reliable
yet noise can travel over ground wires
and power wires
into the deck so
an audio file that just has this
rudimentary knowledge of
how things work will automatically
assume that there must be some merit to
these things so
they go out and and uh try to uh
you know buy some of these products and
uh
let's start with one of them that's uh
quite popular in the
forums and online a com a company called
uptown audio
uh makes this product called ether
region
cost 640 and unlike our uh
product that we were looking at uh that
was eight ports for 20 bucks this one's
only four ports
and uh cost 640 dollars so
you could buy 30 of the other ones for
one of these so needless to say
it's not a economical solution so
it's you know it's got to do some magic
now this is an expensive product for
them to actually build because they've
built their own switch from scratch
although they use a soc subsystem that
already does some of this
they have built enough custom logic
around it that if this did
something useful then you could sort of
you know convince yourself maybe it's
worth it although this little hobby box
is a giveaway that
you're not buying luxury goods here
going way down to
where it implies that the fidelity is
improved
is that it's at the heart of this thing
is this low
jitter digital uh differential digital
isolator chips
and ultra low jitter differential
re-clocking flip-flops
now i know what these things mean but i
don't think you need to know what they
mean
but an audiophile reading this just
immediately
immediately thinks jitters lord and if
jitter is lower
then must be that my noise floor is
going down and if my noise floor has
gone down maybe
things sound more open maybe less jitter
things sound more analog
like which audiophiles like to think
analog is always better than digital
and they run up and purchase this uh
and uh hook it up to their system
so as i said we got one of these to
evaluate and i
tested it one of the key things here you
want to know
is that jitter and noise are extremely
easy to measure
so when a company says i've got product
x and it lowers general
noise and they don't show you that the
noise and the jitter are reduced you can
immediately write them off
because they must either be incompetent
or they don't even know if this thing
reduces noise in jitter jitter is a
variation in the clock
so designers know how to measure
jitter and we can even measure with
electronic audio devices which i'll show
you in a minute
so antenna is already up of you know
if this reduces uh noise and jitter show
me
you know if you don't show me then i'm
just gonna contest
the claim and that's what happened so
this is the box
as you see it's got one port at one end
which is supposed to be is clean
ultra clean output then it's got the
other side which is sort of a dirty side
so you plug in your
ethernet in here that comes from your
wall
and then it's the other side that's the
uber clean but there is also a claim
that these other ports a ports
also do something so i thought well okay
we measure everything
um now one of the arguments about these
devices is that if you go tell them they
don't work
they say well how good is your system
maybe your system's not resolving enough
to see the difference that this makes so
i said fine for my testing i'm going to
use a streamer from company called
matrix audio
called matrix i it's a dac with a
streaming functionality built in so it
has an ethernet port and wi-fi
it's a thousand dollar dac and streamer
so not cheap it's not a 10
budget part and it has exceptional
performance not quite the max
best of the best that a dac can do but
extremely good as i'll show you in a
second
so i uh plugged this in and first tested
the matrix
element i with just my dirty wall
ethernet or cheap ethernet switch that i
have
and i'm actually streaming audio to it
um from
roon media player so i'm simulating
exactly what
happens in real life you know you have a
roon player or j river what have you
upnp whatever protocol you're using
that's what i'm using so i'm not using
my audio precision to
send data to it i'm actually using a
player
on a computer and i'm running roon
and i'm pushing data to it and the data
is going over ethernet switch going to
this
uh element i and spitting out analog
output
so that's key remember i'm analog it was
comes out of the streamer
there is no uh other output from a dac
if you will
it's got audio and that's the main thing
that matters is the audio remember
so we look at cyanad which i talked
about before is a sum of uh
noise and distortion relative to our
signal is 113 db
lower than our signal this is at
threshold of
uh hearing which means that this stream
is
guaranteed to be transparent it
its distortions are below minus 120 db
that's 5 db better than our hearing
threshold and dynamic range
so this streamer what comes out of it is
what's in your music
something wrong with it is something
wrong with the music this device is not
contributing anything to it
despite using the dirty ethernet that's
going into it
it's producing incredible performance
but maybe it gets better if we uh use
ether region first let's start with port
a which is their semi-good ports
and run the exact same test
do you see anything different no
nothing's different even down to this
little tick over here minus 121 db
no difference whatsoever if there were
jitter
that would show up around here if there
was noise this would go up
cyanide would reduce this phd plus n
would go up
you know voltages are identical 4.05 for
4.053 basically if you breathe on this
device that little one digit changes but
essentially there's
no difference whatsoever on the a side
of this
switch so let's go to the fancy port hey
let's go to part b that's supposed to
make a big difference
what do we see absolutely nothing is
still 113 over here
still a little better than -1 or 20.
4.05 world
one killers clock nothing has changed
absolutely nothing has changed
and remember again i'm measuring what
comes out of the dac
and the streaming this is all that
matters because that's what you're going
to listen to right the output of the
stream
is going to go to your amplifier and go
to your headphone or to a
speaker system that's what you listen to
you don't listen to ethernet packets
right
we don't listen to digital data we don't
care what what the box black box doing
upstream
its job is to improve this if 640
is supposed to do that and so far 640
hasn't done us any good whatsoever
compared to a 20 option
so let's talk about jitter um
the device as i said claims to reduce
jitter but the jitters reducing is the
that of the ethernet jitter
and as i said the data is so reliable
there we don't need better clocks but
fine we got that it is possible to
induce jitter in a deck with just noise
so even though you're not mucking with
this clock
we can run a test that'll tell us that
jitter is nevertheless induced and i
won't talk about the details of it now
maybe i'll do a video on that
but we can measure anything that's
happening to that dac
chip that's inside of this streamer
that's done through a standard test we
run called the j-test
it's a basically pure 12 kilohertz tone
that we
play and then we look at this spectrum
of anything around it okay so this
horizontal line is the noise floor of
the deck
and every one of these little ticks is
basically an unwanted signal
okay notice the sensitivity of this test
it's at 160 db
below the zero which is our signal
remember i said threshold availability
is 115
we are 160 that's how deep we can go
we can go 30 40 db past the level that
you can
possibly ever hear and
when we look there we see a little noise
in here little spike in here
minus 140 this could be a power supply
spike or something like that
and these some other ones what they are
doesn't matter
what is important is that um i've got
the cheap switch
my 20 dollar switch in blue then i've
got the red one is the port b
the uber port on this ether region and
look at this the two graphs
land on top of each other where you
can't tell one from the other
nothing has happened these little ticks
did not get reduced did not get
eliminated we even have a little tiny
bit of jitter
a jitter is always symmetrical it shows
up on both sides of our main tone so
there is a tiny bit of jitter at minus
140 db
but the ether region in breadth
eliminate that no look over here
it's still there made no difference
whatsoever
all right well are we done
i said no let's first compare port a and
port b
on this thing because they claim one is
better than the other
does poor and poor dbe make a difference
no
so even on their own product the one
port that they say is dirtier than the
other
they're both extremely good they're both
consistent with
the 20 one now
people may say well there might be some
rf and some
ultrasonic noise that you're not showing
because the previous test is only goes
up to 20 kilohertz
what if there's stuff above it now never
mind that we can't hear the stuff that's
above our hearing range
but let's analyze that anyway so we go
ahead and run
our j test uh jitter test again but this
time i expand the
band with up to 95 kilohertz
uh so it's going way way past our
hearing range there are some spurious
tones in here
and i won't get into why they are here
but
again when i go through
just a 20 no-name switch and i go
through this
absolutely no difference whatsoever so
nothing's been
even high frequency noise is not being
reduced
in this somebody may say
well that's not enough maybe there's
this rf stuff that's getting in there
there's all this high frequency stuff
that
messes everything up in my audio again
remember you don't hear
rf if you could hear rf you go crazy
because you hear the rf from your wi-fi
and your cell phone and everything else
you know thank god we can't hear
rf but hey why don't we uh you know
actually before i tell you that one
that's this test well i'm going to jump
into this this then i'll go back
so i went ahead and uh increased this
the analysis spectrum uh
to over one megahertz and here
i'm just measuring noise okay so
i'm not streaming anything but
everything's connected
so if the switch no name switch is
injecting noise into my
streamer dac then i should be able to
see it as you see in here
it makes no difference which port i use
whether i use my cheap
one or whether i use the uh
ether region nothing has changed not
even a tiny tiny tiny hair has
been moved all the way up to one
megahertz your speakers don't go up to
one megahertz your headphone doesn't go
up to one megahertz not even remotely so
there's absolutely absolutely nothing
there
now if i don't go to one meg which is
this previous test
i can actually go to extremely low
noise levels so now i have juiced up my
audio precision analyzer where
it is now examining noise levels at
minus 160 to minus 180
i mean this is crazy this is like us
trying to hear
noise on the other side of the planet
and
here's a noise spectrum no matter which
switch you use
it makes no difference whatsoever it
just
doesn't we no matter how we skin this
cat no matter whether we look at
jitter noise distortion nothing
nothing nothing remotely has changed
um as a side thing this thing cooks
you know the mass market switch has been
optimized the heck
so that is very power efficient touch
the top of your switch it will not be
worn this little guy
is cooking all along this 640 dollar box
gonna survive
i don't know but it's also wasting this
much power
just sitting there cooking itself doing
nothing useful for you
now people say well i hook this up and i
hear it why didn't you listen to it well
i
listened to it so even though everything
in my body says hey
this is not going to make a difference
hey you got to be objective i could have
said none of this
you know i could have predicted all
those measurements but we still measure
because we want to know
so i went ahead and and uh set up an
interesting test
ethernet and networking is what we call
the asynchronous protocol
when you play audio it's usually a
synchronous protocol
meaning the host generates the packets
and the dac meters them out and is
playing them in unison
networking is designed to be
to not care about timing when a packet
comes from across from youtube servers
to your computer you don't know
indeed on youtube you see a progress bar
usually is ahead of what you're watching
because it tries to pull all the data as
fast as he can
just because so that if there is a drop
in uh throughput all of a sudden he can
write that out and not get a pause and
not get a glitch
so we can take advantage of that in that
when we start to play something the
streamer is gonna
hoover all those bits and suck them in
as much as he can and
store him in his internal buffer and
play so even if we
disconnect the ethernet wire from it
it'll continue playing
as if the heat is still coming but one
of the cool thing
is that when we disconnect the wire we
also disconnect the source of the noise
and jitter
right that's what these audio file
switches are supposed to do
so i ran such a test i'm listening to
the music
with high quality incredibly high
quality
dac and the streamer and headphone
system
and you could unplug and plug this
ethernet
cable as many times as you want nothing
ever happens
anybody who says these things do make it
this difference they should get a loved
one
to do that unplugging and plug in and
have their backs
be against it and raise their finger
when they think
there's been a switch i guarantee you
they will all fail
there's just no way no way you'll hear
and by the way that also proves how
robust tcp ip is that you can disconnect
the physical cable and plug it back in
one or two seconds later and it recovers
as if nothing had happened
it notices that the packages are getting
lost and it waits and waits retransmits
or transmitting eventually
and it gets through so both in listening
tests
and in objective measurements none of
this made a difference
should it have made a difference well
no because anybody who designs a
streamer that knows
anything about good audio performance
will know that this
ethernet data is coming in it's going to
be an ethernet port it's going to be a
cpu
it's going to have a operating system
all of that are quite noisy
so a high performance streamer keeps all
that noise isolated from the dac portion
so that one noise doesn't bleed into the
other one so even if you had the world's
noisiest ethernet
connection the designers know that they
should avoid
letting that noise bleed into the deck
now someone may say well maybe a cheap
streamer would have this problem
my answer is you buying a 640 dollar
network search to fix a cheap streamer
once you get a good streamer
and you don't have this problem and by
the way if that happens why doesn't the
manufacturer show and run the same test
go ahead find the jeep streamer and show
me that there's an improvement
you won't be able to because even in
extreme cases this is so
isolated so removed from where the
business end of our system is it doesn't
make a difference
so with respect to the switch we've
tested it
we've listened to it it does nothing
nothing nothing useful other than taking
away 640 dollars from you
now this is a low cottage industry now
company after companies figured out ah
all i can
all i have to do is take a some switch
and change his power supply and
change his clock and have a little story
i write on a website
and i could also be
in business selling a 20 switch for a
few hundred dollars or even a few
thousand dollars
hey i could do that so a company called
silent
angel has a product called the n8 it's
got eight ports on it
and it's revolutionary product it says
uh makes music more musical and
emotional
how do you make an ethernet switch know
that
to do that to your music packets
what makes what is emotion when it comes
to technical engineering is there a
circuit inside this switch
that says oh this packet of data is
music
and there's something wrong with it i've
got to make it more musical
so clearly this statement is nonsense
but
it follows with what we've talked about
which is ah
lower electrical noise and it you know
lowers interference
remember again all of this is upstream
of our receiver once we get the data we
don't care about this but hey
that's the story and if you look down
here is the standard story oh a better
clock
so lower jitter lower noise less noise
oh medical grade adapter power supply
that must be a good thing
well somebody sent that one to me for
testing us
so let's go look at that this one is
four hundred dollars
a little bit cheaper not six hundred
forty dollars
uh it definitely looks like a generic
switch
so didn't even bother making a fancy
switch for a four hundred dollars
fancy case um i'm not gonna get into the
details of this test but you can uh
this is the standard switch again
um same story did it make a difference
through this absolutely absolutely
absolutely not everything is the same
uh jitter test identical
no difference whatsoever
noise floor clean as a whistle
no difference whatsoever now here i did
another thing
which is hey let's generate a lot of
traffic on the switch
to make it busy so we can generate more
noise
and see if that pollutes
the output of our deck it does not
a generator basically saturated a
gigabit
port piping almost 700 megabits per
second which should never happen see how
home
continuously no difference whether you
use the cheap switch or their switch
makes no difference whatsoever
so i ran a test in here interesting one
so i basically
changing the uh changing one to the
other yeah so
i've got a i'm streaming through this
new switch and i'm capturing the output
and analyzing its distortion using the
audio precision analyzer i'm plotting
that continuously as time goes by
okay while this is happening remember i
said that the streamer buffers a lot of
data so i can disconnect the cable and i
can reconnect it
and things keep going so indeed i did
that
at times i'm not telling you i did that
i unplugged the ethernet cable the
stream i kept playing and before i could
complain and
stop i plug it back in i just connect it
plug it back in
you can see in here down to 0.1 decimal
place of noise and distortion
you cannot see any indication whatsoever
that the cable was plugged in or wasn't
so if the ethernet cable
brings noise then
you should be able to see its effect the
fact that
you can disconnect the cable and connect
it and it absolutely nothing happens in
the switch
means that it doesn't matter whatever
noise and
the jitter or whatever exists on
ethernet cable does not
make its way all the way out to the
output of the deck
listening test again um
this time i did it differently i did it
the way an audio file does
he's been using a regular cheap switch
those buys this 400 dollar search
drives all excited plugs it in
and listens to it and immediately
notices
an improvement there's more detail
there's more air
everything sounds more analog like
veil's been removed his system has never
ever sounded this good
remarkable incredible
guess what when i listened the exact
same thing happened to me
i heard when i plugged in the n8 and the
fancy ethernet switch
all those things happened to me
yes it did but here's the catch
i switched the i went from listening to
the
audio file switch and went to the cheap
generic switch
and the same thing happened again more
air
more veil was removed it was more analog
like
how is that possible we just saw these
measurements that said that's not
possible
am i hearing an improvement the reasons
no
when you're paying attention to what is
what your system is doing
your brain switches operations it goes
from
lean back join music to becoming an
instrument
it's trying to analyze the signal it's
trying to determine whether there's more
fidelity
when you focus you start hearing the
separation between notes you start to
see through with your ears the noise
floor
you start to notice instruments not
because anything's changed
but because you are changing you have
changed
you were turned yourself into a
instrument
and you're now discovering things just
because you have
become different the existing
fidelity has not changed whatsoever it's
just like the mo
you know matrix movie with a kid the
spoon is bending and
and uh says it's not spoon that's
bending it's you that's bending
uh that's exactly what's happened here
so
this is a pitfall for audiophiles to go
buy tweaks of all kinds
no matter how implausible that tweak is
they perceive it improvement and they do
indeed hear it
but it's not the ear that's hearing it
it's the brain that's manufacturing that
because it's analyzing things in
different situations
than the old system so
i listened i heard what people hear
and i'm here to tell you it is not valid
your listening tests have to be proper
when differences become
so small you have to do a blind test get
a loved one
put two switches next to each other and
unplug from one
plug into the other and plug into the
other one have the loved one do that 10
times
and write down you know your vote you
know which one's which
if you get more than eight out of ten
right you're golden
but i guarantee you have no prayer of
telling the difference because there is
no difference
so long video but essentially the
message here is very very clear
these devices don't fundamentally
cannot make a difference except for very
very very
very remote possibility and that remote
possibility
maybe is with the junkiest stack
streamer you could ever come up with and
if such a product
exists why aren't they not showing it
themselves
again anybody who tells you that they
can reduce noise in jitter
ask them for noise and gender
measurements you see them in all my
measurements
what's wrong with them ether region that
company upton
store up and down that they've done
their own measurements and they will
come up with it and will prove us all
wrong
and that measurement that the review is
a year old nothing came out
nothing ever came out they've made that
promise many many times they're going to
write a white paper
where's the white paper where's the
measurement nothing
all they talk about is if you look at
the signal
on ethernet how it's improved and uh my
answer to that is simple i don't care
how you improve the
ethernet signal i don't listen to the
ethernet signal
that's a digital stream a listen to the
output of a dac
and every test that i've shown you in
here is measuring the performance the
analog
waveform coming out of the deck that's
all i care about i don't care what's
happening inside the
soup that's all those circuits inside i
care about what is the output of the
stack
inside of a streamer and if you don't
improve that
you don't deserve a penny from okay
hopefully that's been useful um
i'll try to do more reviews and and then
sprinkle them here and there with these
uh
debunking videos as people call them
thanks for watching
and see you in the next video bye